but he came in the first day of
rehearsal and he said i heard you was
slept with the freddie mercury and the
hall of notes guy i said
where did you hear that he said i read
it on wikipedia
for my podcast there's some they got it
from your podcast and somebody put it on
wikipedia well the little one from
hall notes we know that's true uh john
oates you had sex with but we don't know
about freddie so freddie
freddy krueger freddie mercury's not
freddie mercury you didn't sleep with
i think i did mike i mean
and i think that was him i mean was he
nice that mouth
when i saw that mouth on the thing i
said oh
i know that guy now did you do you
remember him being nice
club what do you remember him being nice
and kind it was
very nice oh yeah you guys hook up you
go your separate ways nobody gives a
[ __ ]
right is that what happened you just
kind of had a fling
look the club was letting out it was
like two or whatever in the morning
i had been making a movie in munich and
i had some time off and i went to berlin
and i realized i couldn't understand
anybody still there so i
went to london where i knew some people
so so i was and then i went back to
berlin
during that same night do you remember a
conversation you had with freddie that
night maybe
anything bless you you just remember
having sex and you don't remember
talking like
i'm writing this song bohemian rhapsody
nothing nothing comes to mind
no no i don't think what we did
came up you know are
just two people who were attracted to
each other
and wanted to uh touch and that was it
and the next morning you left
he left that was it done i never saw him
again
i didn't get his number or anything well
did he just say well nice meeting you
uh you know it was a long long time ago
i don't remember
well what about uh john oates what about
him he's
very talented they had a lot of my
favorite song song
i love the songs he didn't do any
singing though
that time what was what's your favorite
whole note song
they had so many good big hits oh they
had so many hits man eater
adult education uh yeah they had a lot
of great songs
a man eater man eater yes
that well there you go